we've heard some news that you are
considering retiring soon you did I did
when we started it was like okay I'm
producing all the revenue and so if I
die today what happens to all these
employees well they're screwed and we
said okay then we need to measure nonay
Revenue it's very hard to find
somebody's done a brand transfer like
hours Paul Harvey Jr very seldom can
take Paul Harvey seat but we did figure
out a one to many had a chance I didn't
put the whole thing on my daughter
Rachel Cruz's shoulders we have now
raised up a George camel and a Jade
warshaw and a Ken Coleman so if Rachel
is going and doing a book that's non-day
revenue or if Ken Coleman goes and
speaks somewhere that speaking fee is a
non-day revenue right we wanted it to be
a 50% of the revenue was not mine and
the great news is is that in 2023 we're
at about
78% survive if I'm not here we built the
business models out in such a way that
it's not Dave dependent to continue to
run for instance our high school
curriculum is a 1520 million business
they don't care if I'm alive or not